Я вважаю що
Контрнаступ продовжується безумовно Це
відбувається
повільніше ніж хотілось би я думаю що
наші пілоти точно стануть топганами 21
століття ілюдія
Китай навіть продовжують військову
співпрацю купуючи зброю у Росії це не
підтримка України Ви маєте чіткі
підтвердження Щодо цієї такої співпраці
Ми дуже близькі до нашої Перемоги Я
сподіваюсь що ми цього разу здивуємо
світ
це трофейне російська техніка її
привезли сюди до дня незалежності
України 24 серпня виповнюється півтора
року відтоді як почалася повномасштабна
війна кінця який поки не видно про це
говоритиму з Андрієм єрмаком він
керівник офісу президента і як вважає
дехто в Україні більш впливова людина
ніж сам президент
Ярмак Дякую що погодилися на інтерв'ю з
нами Україна відзначає вже другий день
незалежності під час війни який у вас
настрій знаєте це надає якихось
особливих відчуттів
дійсно єдності всієї країни
єдності якщо в Минулого року це була
єдність щоб вистояти сьогодні це єдність
і наша сила щоб перемогти це велика
гордість за країну Це велика гордість за
наших друзів і партнерів які навколо нас
я можу сказати що це реально свято таке
дуже глибоке і дуже емоційне і ви
говорите про настрій на перемогу але ми
бачили нові соціологічні опитування
згідно з якими лише 49% українців
налаштовані оптимістично
Я не знаю які ви дивитесь цифри
знаєте Я
президент я команда ми дуже часто
буваємо в першу чергу на
фронті ми спілкуємось останній раз
Наприклад ми були і в 16 бригадах
безпосередньо спілкувалися з нашими
героями ми відчуваємо не цифри на папері
А ми відчуваємо людей на місці людей в
містах до яких їздить президент дуже
часто і я не вірю в цифри 40%, які
лише які оптимістичні
я розумію що люди втомилися я розумію що
безумовно жити кожного кожної вечора
коли ти йдеш спати І ти не розумієш що
буде відбуватися вночі безумовно Це
важко важко всім
Але я вважаю що дух українські
він всі ці більше ніж півтора року
демонструє всьому світу наскільки
українська нація сильна і наскільки вона
спроможна дивувати вже багато разів весь
світ давайте
не будемо забувати що колись нам давали
тільки три дні потім декілька місяців
але вже півтора року і ми не просто
захищаємося ми звільняємо нашу землю і
так буде до останнього сантиметру нашої
Землі яка по праву по закону за нормами
міжнародного права належать Україною в
міжнародно визначених кордонах це є
нашою ціллю
і це буде нашою перемогою
поговоримо про ситуацію на фронті
Контрнаступ не виправдовує очікування а
очікування були дуже високими але
прогрес повільний У чому полягали
помилки
знов таки знов таки
очікування кого
І
знаєте коли
це війна і сьогодні ніхто не може
передбачити на 100%, як буде розвиватися
події я можу тільки вам сказати що
кожного дня Ми маємо
невеликі але прогрес безумовно Це
відбувається
повільніше ніж хотілось би і тому є
абсолютно
[музика]
причини в першу чергу це дуже велика
площина замінованості землі
по-друге ми досить нам не вистачає
озброєння і
по-третє в нас інша філософія чим ми
відрізняємося від росіян Ми думаємо про
наших людей а росіяни жодним чином
росіяни не рахують людей Вони для них
просто Вибачте але таке м'ясо яке вони
вони кидають і вони навіть багатьох
вбитих своїх не забирають з поля бою і
тому безумовно Це війна не тільки
Росії проти України це війна світоглядів
Києві на філософії це війна диктатури і
демократії і але я не я не погоджуюсь з
вами Я вважаю що
Контрнаступ продовжується він ще раз
кожного дня має хоча маленькі але
прогрес і безумовно щось якесь речі
змінюються тому що ну кожного дня щось
відбувається і я сподіваюсь що ми цього
разу здивуємо світ більш того ми от
сьогодні тільки зранку повернулися до
України після дуже
вдалих візитів до Данії Швеції
Нідерландів Греції повернулися з дуже
гарними новинами Я думаю що я знаю я
говорив наприклад з
генералом сирським і питав в нього Які
Які відчуття у наших воїнах після новини
що Нам надають конкретно вже кількість
винищувачів ff-16 і він мені повідомив
про те що всі дійсно дуже раді і це
дійсно дає додаткове
додатково мотивацію нашим воїнам тому що
дуже скоро Я впевнений ми будемо і
опанувати в небі я думаю що наші пілоти
точно стануть топганами 21 століття
угорімо про це за хвилину літаків ще
немає потрібен певний час але ж у планах
ніколи не було відвойовувати 10
кілометрів за два місяці чи не так під
час Контрнаступ ну знаєте Я думаю що ви
точно не знаєте який би вточений план
і тому це
дуже важко там обговорювати коментувати
Ще раз вам можу сказати що кожного дня
Ми маємо певний прогрес і якщо ви
повернетеся декілька місяців тому
давайте відверто хто думав рік тому
що Україна не просто зможе
боротися і просто не дати просуватися
росіянам а вже почне звільняти територію
я вам можу сказати навіть в політичних
подіях знаєте навіть за декілька днів до
проведення зустрічі на рівні
радників з питання національної безпеки
і політичних радників вджедів
Саудівській Аравії мало хто вірив що це
відбудеться мало хто вірив що будуть
певні країни
глобального півдня присутні сьогодні всі
говорять всі під час всіх зустрічей що
це великий успіх за два дні в цей успіх
вірили
дуже небагато людей тому Давайте
дивитися абсолютно на реальні речі і
давайте дивитися що буде відбуватися
найближчі місяці і давайте менше розмов
більше діла да тому що коли сьогодні
наше партнери чітко бачать коли ми
дійсно маємо все що необхідно ми маємо
результат ми досить сьогодні багато чого
потребуємо Я дуже вдячний нашим
партнерам я дуже
якщо ми говоримо сьогодні з вами я хотів
би сказати що за велику допомогу
Німеччині і дійсно сьогодні Німеччина є
одним із лідерів щодо допомоги України і
дуже потужні заяви останніх днів і
Міністра закордонних справ і канцлера і
так далі за що ми дуже-дуже вдячні і я
вважаю що разом Ми Точно переможемо і
переможемо безумовно Ми хотіли б
перемогти Як можна скоріше Тому що чим
скоріше настанеться перемога тим
безумовно багато і інших питань і
кризисів які викликали ця війна їх можна
буде подолати і про це формула Миру
президента Зеленського
ви згадали про f16 ми чули від кількох
представників уряду що Україна хотіла
крім f-16 ігри пенів на яких вже
почалися тренування також літаки
єврофайтер хоча ще немає жодних
зобов'язань чи буде Україна просити
єврофайтер у Німеччині
ви знаєте сьогодні треба від це
будування повітряного флоту нового
повітряного флоту України Я не можу себе
віднести я не військовий безумовно цим
займаються люди які є професіоналами але
наскільки мені відомо є
декілька видів літаків які можна по
можливо поєднати тому безумовно цей
процес він наразі відбувається нині це
не на вашому порядку денному ми говоримо
за всіма партнерами
[музика]
Йосифа
Ви також говорите про ракети Таурус
Німеччина вагається щодо їхньої передачі
тривають дискусії чи варто змінювати їх
ню програмне забезпечення щоб Україна не
могла використати їх проти Росії звідки
така недовіра чому не вдалося переконати
Німеччину що ви застосуєте їх так як
заявляєте ви знаєте наскільки по-перше
ми говоримо за всіма партнерами і це
наше принципова позиція це стосується і
літаків і це як стосується дальнобійної
зброї а вона нам потрібна для того щоб
звільняти нашу територію
ми не
плануємо його використовувати проти
російської території і це лунає і це є
чіткою позицією яку висловлює
керівництво нашої країни що стосується
консультації Ну ви знаєте кожного разу
рішення наших партнерів щодо
надання нам якихось принципових дуже
позицій воно супроводжується внутрішньою
процедурою внутрішньої консультації Я
впевнений що Німеччина позитивно
вирішити і це питання я знаю що
дійсно сьогодні цей діалог відбувається
Але я думаю що он завершиться позитивно
для України і ми дійсно отримаємо від
Німеччини те що нам потрібно
час від часу на заході піднімається тема
переговорів з Росією
переговорів до того як Росія піде з усіх
українських територій Україна заявляла
Що це не варіант але тиск на Україну
зростає
ви знаєте я не знаю не чув
бо є присутній Практично на всіх
переговорах високого рівня щоб хтось із
відповідальних політиків лідерів країн
світу піднімав питання щодо якихось там
переговорів всі говорять про те що
Україна сама буде вирішувати коли і за
яких умов
погодитись на будь-які переговори а
позиція України Вона дуже чітка Вона
всім відома що Поки російські війська
знаходяться на нашій території нині про
які перемовини не може йти мови але ми
також знаємо що наприклад у США певні
кандидати які зараз намагаються отримати
номінацію на майбутні вибори говорять
про зупинку підтри мки України Чи є у
вас План Б
дивіться Ми живемо в демократичних
країнах в кожній цих країн люди мають
мати ту позицію яку вони мають право але
ми знаємо про потужну підтримку народів
і Сполучених Штатів і Німеччини і Дані
зараз і Швеції і Нідерландів і багато
інших країн тому я не розумію Про які
План Б Ви говорите на сьогоднішній день
В нас немає питань щодо підтримки
України не тільки нашими головними
партнерами країнами j7 країнами НАТО
країнами Європейського союзу а то що в
країнах є процеси Хтось має там іншу
точку зору ну це нормально це демократія
і в меншість закінчується
ви згадали держави глобального півдня
Україна намагається бути більш активною
дипломатично з цими країнами водночас
нині триває самі БРІКС який об'єднує
Росію і ще чотири країни які не
підтримують Україну
ви знаєте багато з країн БРІКС вони були
присутні в джеді і вони всі висловлювали
підтримку Незалежності територіальної
цілісності суверенітету України і ми
бачимо що сьогодні на цій зустрічі
Bricks е-е нема президента країни
терориста і ви знаєте що багато з
контактів консультації які ми проводили
Протягом останнього часу наприклад візит
африканських лідерів Я впевнений змінив
їх ставлення до цієї війни до того що
відбувається Я думаю що Bricks може
стати ще більш потужним і впливовим якщо
там не буде Росії
але всі ці держави не приєдналися до
санкцій проти Росії Індія і Китай навіть
продовжують військову співпрацю купуючи
зброю у Росії це не підтримка України
Ви маєте чіткі підтвердження Щодо цієї
такої співпраці
ви знаєте ми говоримо з цими країнами ми
в постійному діалозі але це процес це
важливий процес і ви знаєте їх учність
сьогодні в
обговоренні української формули Миру це
є свідченням того що для них в першу
чергу важливо Це
по-друге що ми поділяємо однакові
цінності і принципи і сьогодні це
завдання щоб ці країни також були разом
з Україною але це поступовий процес це
потребує
зустрічі потребує розмов які
відбуваються в нас постійно безумовно ще
багато роботи але ще раз повернуся до
зустрічі в джейді всі ці країни були
присутні всі ці країни говорили і їх
присутність там
говорить про те що їм не байдуже
що відбувається в Україні і всі вони
чітко не було жодних зауважень і жодних
дискусій щодо територіальної цілісності
навіть лунала дуже чітко територіальна
цілісность України в міжнародно
визначених кордонах
Не було жодних
сперечань щодо наприклад
суверенітету незалежності України Так
сьогодні наша формула наша ціль сьогодні
щоб весь світ був впевнений по-перше ми
сказали що ми відкриті ми готові з усіма
країнами які поважають нашу незалежність
територіальну цілісність суверенітет ми
готові говорити знову ж таки Китай і
Росія проводять спільні військові
навчання Індія купує зброю у Росії це не
підтримка України
знаєте я вам можу тоді привести
інший приклад це ж не причина коли
сьогодні на Україну летять ракети і
летять дрони і так далі там теж є
елементи які виробляються в країнах не
Global Soul А в інших країнах світу але
це не означає що ці країни підтримують
російську агресію це означає що світ
дійсно сьогодні трансформується сьогодні
країни розуміють що безумовно там
неможливо торгувати з країною терористом
неможливо надавати їм якісь технічні
можливості неможливо з ними торгувати
тому процес наприклад вихід у компанії
російського ринку він не відбувся отак
от за один день але він продовжується
він продовжується і ми маємо якщо ви там
вирішили там навіть останніми днями
декілька
компаній європейських вирішили покинути
російський ринок Тому цей процес не
припиняється Також санкціями я вам можу
навести приклад що Коли почалися санкції
не одразу багато санкцій дуже красиво
мали красиву назву але вони не працювали
чому ми з паном макфолом створили окрему
групу яка не зупиняє свою роботу і
сьогодні яка видає рекомендації і
сьогодні 70% наших рекомендацій вони вже
втілені в європейських санкціях в
американських санкціях в канадських
санкціях наприклад Я продовжую боротися
щодо санкцій проти російських
пропагандистів
але ми говоримо про спільні військові
навчання китайська і російська армія
мають спільні навчання це відрізняється
від не підтримки санкцій
цього для цього Ми продовжуємо цю роботу
і для цього Ми продовжуємо і коли
сьогодні Китай стане частиною в тому
числі процесу роботи над втіленням
формули Миру президента Зеленського це
буде також впливати і на це
співробітництво але ви знаєте офіційна
позиція Китаю вона інша весь час про це
говорите я вам запитав у вас є
чіткі докази конкретно якщо вони є Будь
ласка надайте ми представимо це
китайським колегам тому що в нашому
діалозі Ну ви знаєте ми не робимо
якихось заяв якщо ми щось ми дуже
відкриті дуже щирі
з колегами якщо Ми щось маємо
підтвердження що ось так виробляєме
якесь озброєння російське воно має
елементи які виробляються в інших
країнах Ми беремо ці Докази і надаємо
партнерам якщо ми маємо сьогодні що
якісь країни допомагають обходити
санкції ми збираємо Докази і передаємо
партнерів Тобто ми дуже предметно
спілкуємося з партнерами Якщо у вас є
такі докази надайте мені про ці навчання
повідомлялося публічно іноді теж щось
публікується але без доказової бази Ми
дуже чітко
відслідковуємо все І якщо Сьогодні наш
експерти або експерти наших партнерів
знаходять якісь докази то безумовно ми
нічого не тримаємо і ми одразу Працюємо
з партнерами як ми працюємо Я хотів би
закінчити з пропагандистами коли ми
надали перелік людей які сьогодні
відкрито виступають проти заходу проти
в
конкретних країн але які мають сьогодні
нерухомість там які приїжджають
відпочивати і так далі ми знаходимо це і
передаємо передаємо нашими партнерами ця
робота триває Але можу вам сказати що
вона не закінчена
це процес
у паблік також публікувалися Митні
декларації які свідчать про те що
китайські компанії експортують наприклад
бронежилети
Повірте все що має
доказову базу Вони збираються і
передається колегам нічого не
залишається без нашої уваги
іноді це потребує
більше часу іноді відбувається дуже
швидко за вашими оцінками скільки ще
триватиметься війна
Я би не хотів зробити прогнозів це таке
неблагодарна справа
Я вважаю що треба всім і робити те що
ми можемо і навіть більше Для того щоб
наближати нашу перемогу
наше бажання Перемоги наше єднання всієї
українській нації воно безпрецедентне
єднання світу безпрецедентне але ви
знаєте я можу вам сказати що зараз дуже
важливий момент тому що
мені здається ми дуже близькі до до
нашої Перемоги але це відрізок по-перше
ніхто не знає скільки він буде тривати А
по-друге знаєте
пройдено дуже великий шлях і я ще раз
хочу сказати Я з дуже з великим
розумінням і з повагою ставляться всі
втомлені Це дуже важко Ми живемо в війні
вже
навіть ніж півтора року але я настільки
Вірю в силу духу укрназ українців я
настільки вірю і не тільки просто вірю
тому що я є але я спілкуюсь Коли ми
виїжджаємо я бачу очі людей різного віку
як вони ми на своїй землі і це надає от
ту необхідну енергію яка надихає яка дає
мотивацію Ну і плюс Дуже надихає от
зараз ми ще раз хочу повернутися
повернулися з
цих візитів до європейських країн і ви
знаєте як ставляться до України сьогодні
люди в різних країнах ми це відчували і
в Берліні і в Парижі в Римі і зараз в
Копенгагені і в Стокгольмі і в Афінах і
в
Нідерландах і так далі войтховені
світ сьогодні на стороні добра світ
сьогодні на світлій стороні люди прості
люди сьогодні вони
і це це точно завершиться нашою
перемогою сьогодні про неї не говорять
як ми вам бажаємо сьогодні всі говорять
Ми віримо в ваших перемог
але знаєте Хтось говорить громко хто
говорить тихенько але
всі вірять в нашу перемогу а ми
безумовно Нічого більш бажаного ніж
перемогти ніж щоб на нашу Землю прийшов
в мир нічого не
існує Я думаю завтра в день незалежності
багато хто буде про це говорити І це
дійсно найбільша Мрія і
я думаю що
ми маємо настільки Прекрасну країну
настільки країну яку все ж таки любить
Боже що ми точно дуже скоро будемо
радіти коли мир прийде на нашу землю
дякую